your whole life you've been running
around trying to be the Cosby Show
so what if I was there's something to
seeing a black doctor and black lawyer
living in a loving marriage raising
happy stable children with no one
questioning the Huxtables will
make-believe son maybe but the dreams
they created we're real oh my god I'm so
glad you feel that way whenever I get
stuck I ask myself what would Claire
Huxtable do I do the exact same thing
you do
except I ask our Lord and Savior who
died on the cross Myles fans the
constables good - I invested in the
Huxtables they made me believe that I
could have a family like them and then
that news about Bill Cosby hit and that
was devastating we all were it was awful
it blew up everything I thought I knew
whose son it was one show let it go
that's my point
pops we get so few chances and when we
do something and we do it well it's
special and when we mess it up we mess
it up for everybody that's coming up
behind us it's like we're carrying
everybody's dreams on our back
you